[Musique]
ce qu'une existence effet d'une vie ou
de plusieurs vies depuis longtemps je me
pose la question
aujourd'hui quand je travaille sur moi
et quand je regarde ce que j'ai réalisé
le chemin que j'ai parcouru je me rends
compte que j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
plusieurs vies
tout d'abord prenons la première quand
tout à chacun quand je suis né puis que
je venu enfant puis adolescent mes
parents étaient plutôt des personnes
pauvres avec la pauvreté sur eux on
retrouvait aussi un petit peu
l'alcoolisme la violence ils ont décidé
de prendre un restaurant et avec mes
frères et soeurs on s'est vite retrouvé
à amener des tâches qui n'était pas
forcément celle des enfants épluché
jusqu'à très tard le soir des légumes
nettoyer la vaisselle enfin toutes ces
corvées et très vite on s'est rendu
compte que pour s'en sortir il fallait
qu'on trouve un espèce de jeu à mettre
en place une situation de vie qui peut
être raisonnable pour nous est
acceptable et donc on se lançait des
petits défis qui fera la plus grande des
pelures de pommes de terre qui suivra le
plus de verre un tel temps et on est
vraiment resté dans ce dans ce cadre là
pendant très longtemps on a réussi à
stabiliser l'entreprise familiale et est
très vite
le sport s'est imposé comme échappatoire
donc je courais beaucoup je monte aux
arbres avec mes frères et soeurs et
beaucoup de choses comme ça et la moto
est arrivée et puis moi je n'ai pas pris
tout à fait comme un moyen de transport
mais plutôt comme un moyen de liberté
d'échappatoire est un petit peu trop
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça me coûte le
véhicule dans lequel je suis c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment important
d'avoir cette notion de toujours
remonter des défis parce qu'en fait je
crois que je vivais pas ma vie comme
j'aurais dû la vivre c'était celle que
mes parents avaient choisi il voulait
que je reprenne le restaurant et quand
vous avez une une vie qui est
et déjà prévu que c'est celle que vous
connaissez pas ce que vous ne connaissez
pas d'autres vous rendez compte qu'un
accident bah ça peut être l'occasion de
changer de vie très vite je me suis
retrouvé donc avec cet accident un
accident banal on glisse dans un dans un
virage on tombe sur un caillou on se
casse le dos quand je dis que c'est une
certaine banalité c'est pas une banalité
mais c'est ce qui arrive à beaucoup de
gens aujourd'hui c'est ce qui se passe
après qu'il devient justement très fort
pour la vie d'une personne
j'étais dans le coma et je me suis
retrouvé à l'hôpital avec bunge
handicapées jusqu'au niveau de la
poitrine tous mes membres inférieurs ne
fonctionnait plus une grande souffrance
et puis cette idée cette idée vraiment
profond de d'échapper à tout ça le
suicidant ça a été très fort pendant
très longtemps jusqu'à ce que je retombe
dans un coma à cause d'un problème
pulmonaire et que je me retrouve dans ce
fameux tunnel blanche si vous en avez
pas entendu parler vous en entendrez
parler moi je ne connaissais pas et
c'est vrai que à ce moment là on se
retrouve dans une situation dans
laquelle on est bien mais on a juste un
problème parce que je suis appelé c'est
un problème on se regarde on se retrouve
pas dans la cas de jugement mais plutôt
dans une réalité de ce qu'on a réalisé
dans sa vie et là on se dit qu'est ce
que j'ai fait qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas
fait qu'est ce que j'aurais dû faire et
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression d'avoir le
choix moi qui voulais mourir soit de
passer de l'autre côté ou soit de rester
et de repartir avec avec l'idée d'avoir
des pelures en bagage puisque j'ai pas
trop un grand chose à montrer ce jour là
je suis parti en disant eh bien il faut
que je vive ça a été vraiment un essor
où un un tremplin pour repartir dans la
vie et ça a été comme une nouvelle
compétition devient je vis comme ça j'ai
toujours été habitué comme ça mais la
seule chose c'est que je voulais plus
vivre que pour moi je me suis dit si je
veux vivre si je me retrouvais à nouveau
dans ce tunnel blanc là avec quelque
chose il faut que je vive pour moi avec
les autres et pour les autres c'était
vraiment quelque chose de très important
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir avoir une
raison d'être là ensuite
bah bien tout ce qui peut se mettre en
avant dans la vie d'une personne
handicapée
comment je vais m'en sortir donc le
premier combat ça a été de réussir à
tenir dans un fauteuil alors très
souvent on prend le fauteuil comme
quelque chose de difficile à accepter
moi je peux vous dire que sans lui
serait très malheureux parce que je
pourrai pas me déplacer
donc ça c'est déjà la première chose à
accepter ensuite de pouvoir avoir cette
notion de perspective de vie qu'est ce
que je vais faire demain comment je vais
m'en sortir et surtout est-ce que je
vais être quelqu'un ça paraît ça paraît
quelque chose de tout à fait anodin pour
beaucoup d'entre nous mais se dire
est-ce que je vais être quelqu'un c'est
parce que parce que je ne savais pas du
tout ce qui allait m'arriver je me suis
tapé comme comme j'ai pu ça a été comme
vous voyez ça va aujourd'hui et je me
suis dit ben je prendre le mot facteurs
sport à ses seuls que j'avais deux comme
communication réelle avec le reste de la
delà de la population de métro
contemporain et j'ai décidé de faire du
tennis de table mais j'ai décidé de le
faire vraiment comme jeudi avec cette
notion de le faire avec les autres et
pour les autres et j'en fait avoir un
résultat positif pour moi aussi bien
évidemment le tennis de table je suis
devenu international de tennis de table
donc je joue à un grand niveau en un an
pour nationale 1 français et puis au
niveau international dans dans beaucoup
de deux niveaux au qu'on appelle
l'équipe de france mais voilà pas
l'équipe de france réelle mais enfin pas
loin et je me suis rendu compte qu'à
travers ce sport à travers ses voyages
sur sur le territoire national et
international en fait ce qui
m'intéressait le plus c'était les
rencontres en fait je me suis bien rendu
compte que c'était pas un avion qui nous
emmener en voyage c'est les personnes
qui ont rencontré et je peux vous
assurer que j'étais très riches là
dessus parce que j'ai rencontré des
personnes exceptionnelles dans ma vie
c'était vraiment très très important à
ce niveau là et de pouvoir partager à
travers le monde avec des cultures
différentes des des envies différentes
et avec ses valeurs c'était très
important et très enrichissant donc
j'avais
que 22 ans lors de mon accident et ce
qui a été vraiment important aussi c'est
l entourage souvent on oublie on pense à
la personne handicapée on oublie son
entourage pour ma femme donc le mon ami
à ce moment là elle a été là avant
l'accident
pendant l'accident et après l'accident
et dans une reconstruction on veut aussi
construire une famille parce que c'est
naturel et donc très vite on a voulu
avoir des enfants
et là on s'est retrouvé à nouveau dans
une nouvelle compétition de vie parce
que comme je vous lis en gt1 je suis
handicapé jusqu'au niveau de la poitrine
donc tous les organes sexuels tout tout
ce qui pouvait avoir cette facilité pour
avoir des enfants dans un cadre naturel
on ne l'avait pas et donc pour aller
très vite on se rapprocher de la
solution bébé éprouvette
mais je rends un hommage aux
accompagnants aujourd'hui parce que on a
essayé quinze fois avec ma femme 15 fois
dans la tente dans dans cette espèce de
devis qui pouvait continuer après nous
mais surtout aussi dans bassar à terre
c'était difficile et cette persévérance
qu'elle a eue j'ai trouvé ça génial donc
je rends hommage aujourd'hui et je me
rends bien compte que c'est quelque
chose qui nous a apporté puisque j'ai
trois enfants et je suis même grand-père
donc voila et c'était très important
mais ce qu'était ce qui était aussi très
important dans cette action c'est se
rend compte de ce qu'ils étaient comme
je disais utile dans la vie des
personnes qui étaient dans une condition
veut valide moi mon obsession c'était de
pouvoir apprendre à mon enfant ou à mes
enfants à faire du vélo ça paraît tout
bête
je sais que mon grand-père avait appris
à mon père mon père m'avait appris c'est
peut-être l'un des seuls moments où il
ya justement 7,7 cette force familiale
et d'amitié ou qui nous restait je me
rappelle de sa main quand je suis parti
pour la première fois en vélo et j'ai
réussi à prendre à mes enfants à faire
des vélos et puis j'ai presque devenu un
professionnel parce que j'ai appris à la
moitié de la commune à faire du vélo
c'était c'était je vous assure une
quelque chose de merveilleux et en
refusant ensuite il nous fallait une
maison et donc comme je voulais
participer à tous j'ai fait un petit peu
la baisse il est et je me suis retrouvé
à nouveau à l'hôpital parce que je me
suis fait un espoir en faisant du plâtre
ou je ne sais quelle attaque à l'action
c'était complètement différent et je me
suis rendu compte de la richesse que ça
apportait de faire des choses ensemble
je me suis retrouvé à l'hôpital et j'ai
dû m'attend là ça vaut quand même le
coup un thé les enfants sont là ta femme
est là des amis sont là et tu as quand
même créer quelque chose et je trouvais
que c'était ça cette force là et j'ai
vraiment il vraiment eu l'impression
mais c'est pas qu'une impression c'est
vraiment quelque chose de rennes qu'on
pouvait créer sa vie de par nos actions
et qu'elle était importante et que tous
les jours on peut faire quelque chose
d'important pour pouvoir se retrouver
dans cette situation là je reviens sur
le sport donc j'étais international et
j'ai préparé la jordanie c'était un je
vais un tournoi international là bas
donc il faut dire que c'est à peu près
trois mois d'entraînement assez intensif
et durant ces trois mois la un coup de
fil à la maison et on me demande de
participer aux élections en étant sur
une liste je ne sais pas pourquoi je dis
d'accord
enfin si je sais pourquoi je suis mais
je veux être tête de liste en fait à
travers tous mes voyages à travers ce
que je faisais j'ai toujours remarqué
que l'on utilisait un petit peu le
handicap comme un faire valoir comme une
bonne action ça veut dire que l'on me
remettais des médailles mais on se
rendait pas compte que derrière il y
avait toute la vie de la personne
handicapée est souvent amer je peux
parler des mers parce que je suis maire
mettez une médaille et c'était la bonne
action de la journée et puis après
parler de sa salle paul vilalte
polyvalente son programme politique
et là je me suis dit non si tu vas aux
élections il est très important que ce
soit moi qui donne les médias et que tu
parles des choses jusqu'au fond et
c'était très important
donc je me propose aux arêtes tête de
liste il me rappelle il me met tête de
liste et je deviens je deviens maire de
ma commune
c'était quelque chose qui était
important parce que ça me donnait deux
choses dans la possibilité de m'exprimer
mais aussi une responsabilité par
rapport aux zones mer et aux autres
personnes en fauteuil on est très peu en
france
je crois qu'on est trois ou quatre
personnes en situation de handicap au
moins paraplégique eux donc ça devenait
mme responsables des deux réussites qui
était vraiment très important travail de
maire c'était quelque chose que je ne
sais pas du tout c'était encore un petit
cadeau de la ville et
donc j'ai fait comme pour le tennis de
table j'ai fait que quand j'étais enfant
j'ai travaillé très dur pour connaître
les dossiers peut être un petit peu
toutes les structures géopolitique que
je connaissais pas du tout avec avec les
administrés des personnes qui
travaillent avec moi la commune on a
travaillé sur les valeurs avant de
travailler sur des projets qu'est ce
qu'on faisait là pourquoi on était là et
comment on peut faire quelque chose de
bien ensemble le projet ça vient après
et après il y avait aussi cette notion
de dire voilà j'ai quand même la chance
d'être l'un des seuls maires en
situation d'handicap il faut qu'on parle
de l'handicap et qu'on emmène le plus
loin possible ça devenait un vrai un
vrai de challenges comme d'habitude et
donc on a commencé par mettre en place
de maisons
adaptable ça veut dire sur la commune on
a une petite commune n'a pas un très
grand budget on a fait vraiment le tour
de toutes les institutions et on a
réussi à faire deux maisons avec eux une
pièce deux chambres une salle de bains
adaptée sauvage au sol enfin voyez
quelque chose qui était quand même très
très sympathique et on a réussi à le
faire que pour 7000 euros
en allant chercher des subventions en
allant chercher des aides et le loyer
modéré et permet de largement de payer
un petit prêt qui va avec
donc c'était très positif on est monté
jusqu'au sénat on a proposé ça en disant
voilà c'est très important rendez vous
compte dans les communes il ya beaucoup
de personnes vieillissantes il ya
beaucoup de personnes en situation de
handicap ils ont toujours une même
entourage culturel social et la du jour
au lendemain si ce casse une jambe chez
nous on a des beaucoup de en un parc
immobilier on va dire de des années 40
50 avec beaucoup d'escalier et envoyait
c'était quand même impressionnant on
voyait une ambulance ni à chercher
quelqu'un d'assez âgées qui s'était
cassé le col du fémur et qu'envoyer
l'ambulance antilles dans la vire au
vert a pu pour un col de fémur
c'était très simple en fait la personne
se retrouve à l'hôpital après en centre
de réadaptation après bâle est aigri et
mais le problème c'est qu'elles
pouvaient pas rentrer chez elles et donc
à l'est au long séjour et puis la
déprime est parce que voyez pas ses amis
tout ce qu'elle a connu toute sa vie
maison de retraite 1er 2e étage
on appelle ça comme ça et la mort et
donc avec ces maisons là on avait cette
alternative de leur permettent de
revenir sur le secteur attendre d
aménagement de leur maison et de pouvoir
revivre et aussi de permettre à une
population de rester là on est allé au
sénat ça a été très très suivi par les
sénateurs
hélas son arrivée des nouvelles
élections et tout est tombé à l'eau
c'est triste c'est un système voilà
c'était plus les mêmes interlocuteurs on
avait toujours le projet qui était
exceptionnelle et qui était très bien
qui était viable et c'est tombé à l'eau
le seul problème c'est qu'on avait un
deuxième défi à monter enfin un deuxième
sujet qui nous apportait beaucoup de
c'était l'accessibilité l'accessibilité
pour aller très vite en 1975
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
quand même besoin d'insérer la
population en situation de handicap dans
la société
donc il ya une question qui s'est posée
il ya une réflexion on arriver jusqu'en
2005 moi ça fait trente ans que je suis
en fauteuil pour vous dire donc en 2005
on a une loi qui était très sympa et qui
dit en 2015 tous les erp et donc tous
les établissements recevant du public
celui ci par exemple doit être adaptée
le seul problème c'est qu'on appelle
législation ni de budget tation derrière
ça veut dire qu'on avait rien rien de
fondamental pour pouvoir le faire
c'était au bon vouloir des personnes et
même pas parce qu'en fait il y avait pas
de budget et très vite on s'est rendu
compte que un maire sur dix ans il y en
a trois presque le premier disait mal
deuxième fera le tri le deuxième dit
là-bas ce sera au troisième le troisième
trimestre de collègues n'ont pas fait
pourquoi je le ferai en 2014 ils se
rendent compte que ce n'était pas
possible
hélas le lance l'adapt 1 c'est la
journée d'accessibilité et on par
surcroît 6 9 ans c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est en 2018 c'est pour
aller jusqu'en 2023 qu'est ce que c'est
pour vous 2023 ces cinq ans qu'est ce
que c'est pour moi c'est cp ce1 ce2 cm1
cm2 c'est ça qu'est ce que c'est c'est
une entreprise dans laquelle on peut pas
rentrer alors qu'on cherche un emploi
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un dentiste
chez qui on peut pas aller alors qu'on a
une rage de dents c'était important de
voir ce que c'est le temps pour nous est
ce que c'est le temps réel donc très
vite on lance une nouvelle action avec
des revendications mais on décide de ce
nom pu le faire qu'avec l'état mais le
fer avec la population et là on lance un
défi à l'état qui a été très simple
qu'est-ce qui est le plus facile
aujourd'hui pour une personne en
situation de handicap comme moi de
monter le kilimandjaro
houas père maire élu de la république de
pouvoir emmener des revendications
j'irai pragmatique contre est au niveau
de l'état
leur kilimandjaro on l'a monté et non
pas avec des sportifs
j'aurais pu prendre des collègues
j'aurais pu prendre ça mais avec des
gens de la société des gens comme vous
il y avait un artisan il y avait un
docteur il y avait un infirmier il y
avait un agriculteur et on a voulu
montrer qu'en fait c'était toute la
société qui était complètement ancré
dans dance est dans cette action là
alors vous voyez là on est monté en haut
du kilimandjaro
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
on était avec des tanzaniens et donc
toutes ces personnes là et je le
remercie aujourd'hui vous allez voir
qu'on va les remercier
ils ont été formidables parce que ils
ont vu qu'on n'était pas des touristes
n'étaient pas non plus des sportives
on était des gens qui portait quelque
chose
les revendications étaient très simple
c'était de pouvoir mettre à dispo nibles
it et dans toutes les communes de france
des rampes adapté ça veut dire que si
par exemple un d'entre vous a une
entreprise et me demande de venir
travailler chez lui c'est pas parce
qu'il ya deux marches qui peut pas me
prends parce que le téléphone à la
mairie où je téléphone à la mairie
j'arrive j'emprunte cette rampe et je
les emmène avec moi c'était quelque
chose de très important parce que c'est
quelque chose de simple que devant
chaque commerce se trouve une petite
sonnette un de façon je vais à la
boulangerie c'est le dimanche matin il
ya déjà six personnes devant nous c'est
très difficile de dire ce que vous
voulez bien vous pousser pour que je
puisse rentrer ou est témoin rentrée on
sonne on a un geste citoyen on sait
qu'il ya quelqu'un sa petite dame avec
une poussette maman ou un papa on se
range la boulangère sors et je dis
qu'est ce que voulez monsieur jean deux
ou trois pages et pas besoin de visiter
la boulangerie à chaque fois donc cette
simplicité là on a essayé de la mettre
en place et on a demandé qu'une partie
de la réserve parlementaire puisse être
utilisée puisqu'elle avait été supprimé
et souhaite en glanant ciblée vers
l'accessibilité pour les mains dites
vous bien que ces rampes ce n'est pas
rien non plus pour les maires parce que
par exemple moi j'ai quatre chapelles
chez nous qui servent une fois dans
l'année pour le pardon j'avais pour 80
mille euros pour pouvoir les aménager
sans encore passer par le patrimoine et
architecture qu'une morale sans doute
bloqués
donc on s'est retrouvé avec cette espèce
de bon sens ça donnait au maire
l'occasion par exemple pour les pardons
de donner la rampe on rentrait en
sortait de lachapelle tu ça posait aucun
problème
devinez on était vraiment dans le coup
de fer 89 milles euros d'économie de les
mettre d'autres choses caen se retrouve
dans cette dans cette situation l'a
emmené quelque chose il faut donner
quelque chose de positif
alors on a mis en place le abc c'était
devant chaque commune de france y aura
un petit autocollant à abc qui montera
le niveau 2 le niveau de l'accessibilité
de la commune si j'ai à tous et
accessible si cb ben c'est en entrant
réalisation et six essais en études
c'est quand même très intéressant parce
que ça mettait les personnes dans la
situation réelle
ça veut dire qu'on demande à la
population de se rapprocher des
personnes
voilà j'ai pu beaucoup de temps et donc
voilà ce que je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire que ma vie ça a été un petit
peu difficile à des moments comme mon
accident je le considère comme un cadeau
ma l'enveloppé c'est vrai que c'est
difficile au début mais ça m'a vraiment
permis de découvrir autre chose et j'en
suis très très content je peux vous
assurer malgré la situation est ce que
j'ai à dire aussi c'est que maintenant
j'ai vraiment eu peur de la mort parce
que moi parce que j'ai une belle vie
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]